- Fourteen superheroes met on the moon
for a top secret gathering.
Fascinating.
Three of them turned out to
be evil villains in disguise.
Uh oh.
How many were real superheroes?
Real superheroes.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure this out.
Now you've had your try,
let's work on it together.
So fourteen superheroes met on the moon.
So let's write that down.
Fourteen met on the moon.
I'll put a little circle
around it like that.
So fourteen met on the moon.
Now of that fourteen, they
tell us that three of them
turned out to be evil
villains in disguise.
So three of them are evil villains.
So of the fourteen,
we're either dealing with
the three evil villains,
or we're dealing with real superheroes.
One way to think about it is
the fourteen are made up of
evil villains or real superheroes.
So this question mark right over here,
this is the real superheroes.
This is what we need to figure out.
And so this relationship could
be written in different ways.
You could write...
You could write that the three villains
plus the question mark, real superheroes,
is going to be equal to the
total number of characters
that met on the moon.
Or you could say, well if
three plus question mark
is fourteen, well then
fourteen minus three,
minus three, is going to
be equal to question mark.
Is going to be equal to question mark.
And you see it right over here.
The fourteen is made up of
three and question mark.
So if you take fourteen minus
three, you're just going to
be left with the number
of real superheroes.
So what's fourteen minus three?
Well, there's several
ways you could do this.
But one way is, let's
see, fourteen minus one
is going to be thirteen.
Fourteen minus two is twelve.
Fourteen minus three is eleven.
So we have eleven is equal...
Eleven is equal to question mark.
Or question mark is equal to eleven,
or there are eleven real superheroes.
Now let's do one more.
Let's do one more.
We found many sea monsters
in the nearby lake.
Nine of them have stripes.
Five of them have spots.
How many sea monsters are in the lake?
So what are they telling us?
So the total...
How many sea monsters in the lake?
This is the total number of sea monsters.
This is what we're trying to figure out,
the total number of sea monsters.
That's how many sea
monsters are in the lake.
And they tell us,
they tell us that nine
of them have stripes.
Nine of them have stripes.
And five of them have spots.
Five of them have spots.
So all of the sea monsters are going to be
the nine that have stripes,
plus the five that have spots.
So we could write nine plus five.
Nine plus five is equal to question mark.
Is equal to question mark.
And so what is nine plus five?
Well you might have
that memorized already.
That is fourteen.
Or if you don't, you could
see say, well let's see.
Nine plus one is going to be ten.
Nine plus two is eleven,
nine plus three is twelve,
nine plus four is thirteen,
nine plus five is fourteen.
So you have fourteen is
equal to question mark.
Or how many sea monsters are in the lake?
Fourteen.